jason sokol who's asses assistant
professor of history at the university
of new hampshire also author of the book
all eyes are upon us race and politics
from boston to brooklyn the conflicted
soul of the northeast let's talk about
that conflict what what do you talk
about in the book jason um
that that is this conflict when it comes
to race and politics in this part of the
country
well i argue that the north in the
northeast
there have basically been two dueling
traditions of race relations
on the one hand
the cities and states of the north that
i study massachusetts new york and
connecticut
have often leapt ahead of the rest of
the nation in terms of
uh
being able to
forge breakthroughs in interracial
democracy and racial equality that's on
the one hand on the other hand
i show how these cities and states have
been just as deeply committed to
patterns of racial segregation
and
episodes of racism and racial violence
as anywhere else in the country so those
forces have been at war i argue
throughout the north's history and even
up until today i find this so
fascinating because as someone who grew
up in massachusetts and saw a lot of
what you wrote about firsthand and now
living in new york and brooklyn actually
see a very different approach that still
has these kind of two sides to race
relations i was so interested to read
about what you wrote let's start a
little bit with massachusetts because of
course massachusetts has this kind of
reputation as this progressive
stronghold of forward-looking uh on on
race or election race relations lgbt
rights of course but at the same time
boston does have a pretty ugly history
of racism and segregation we see it uh
very much so with sports during the 60s
and 70s
and even if you look at boston a city
that on paper
is relatively diverse when it comes to
racial demographics you don't see that
in so many parts of boston because the
racial diversity is sort of segregated
in particular neighborhoods dorchester
and south boston is it this was very
very present to me and so many people i
talked to have seen the same things
jason that you write about in the book
what other elements of this am i missing
in this kind of superficial analysis of
boston
well
it's true many african-americans
for a long time thought of and still
think of boston
as a racist place as a racist city um
you know bill russell on the one hand
was the first african-american to coach
a basketball team in the nba on the
other hand he called boston a flea
market of racism quote unquote so it it
it didn't have a a good reputation for
african americans
in some ways it still doesn't but if you
look at for instance black politics
massachusetts has been a place where
african americans
have been able to win white votes and to
win major offices i tell the story of ed
brooke who was elected
as the first
african-american to be popularly elected
to the u.s senate ever and that was from
massachusetts in 1966.
um i take the story right up to deval
patrick
elected governor in
massachusetts and then re-elected so i
think
in some moments massachusetts has been
able to make good on the lofty history
and has shown itself
uh willing to
you know elect african americans in a
way you know 1966 ed brooke was elected
in massachusetts that would have been
absurd that any southern state would
have elected an african-american to the
u.s senate so
everything you say is true about the
deep racial segregation in boston it's
also true that boston has been a racist
place exploded in violence over bussing
but we all but we shouldn't forget the
other tradition
uh in which
boston
as a city and massachusetts as a state
has actually been a beacon
at moments small moments but but uh but
i argue important ones that we shouldn't
forget and that we shouldn't
underestimate in a review of your book
the boston globe said all eyes are upon
us is about the sizeable gap between the
north's ideals and its reality do you
think that that's a good way to kind of
contextualize why there may be this
discrepancy that that we see sometimes
in the nor northeast the idea that the
ideals are very strongly very strongly
stated and heard by many but something
makes the reality fall short of those
ideals and if so what do you think is
keeping the reality from falling short
of the ideals
well i think it's true and you know this
is
a lot of what we're talking about here
is white americans and their ability or
their inability to really commit
themselves to what it means to living in
an integrated and a racially equal
nation
so
in terms of
uh the ideals many white americans white
northerners had have always had
a
commitment to racial integration in the
abstract if you ask them
you know are you in favor of racial
equality and racial justice they would
say yes of course of course i am
uh and this is what for instance
massachusetts residents would say in the
1960s but then if you ask them well are
you
committed to sending your
white student to school with african
americans they say well you know it
depends what school
depends exactly how that works out if
you ask them
should they be compelled to sell their
home to an african-american
if that person puts in a bid on their
home they would you know
in the 1960s they would have not
necessarily said yes so there's been a
uh many white
northerners have had a
distinction between what it means to be
for
equality in the abstract and then they
hesitate to take the steps uh
that are really required
to bring that society into being and so
that that's what i think um
is relevant and resonant about this
the notion of the gap between the ideals
and the reality so this i think gets us
pretty smoothly into our our discussion
about new york city and brooklyn and
when i moved to new york city from
massachusetts i was immediately
obviously aware of the fact that as you
walk around in your regular day you see
exponentially more racial diversity
particularly in western massachusetts
where i started my show there is an
almost total lack of racial diversity
you basically just see white people and
initially i thought that that speaks so
well of new york city but then once i
got beyond this kind of superficial
level of i see all sorts of people
you start to realize that as you take a
a subway
from yankee stadium for example through
manhattan and into brooklyn that the the
racial makeup of that train
is initially very diverse and starts to
kind of whiten as you go through
manhattan and then slowly but surely the
the the white population starts to
shrink in relation to who's on the train
as you enter and head into brooklyn into
the out of our outer parts of brooklyn
so give us a sense of of what we really
are seeing in new york where there's
this kind of superficial
uh diversity in integration but we still
have pretty significant uh lines drawn
between neighborhoods don't we
yeah i mean new york has always been
unique
partially because of its size
you know uh
seven eight million people
packed into the city
and
that does allow for a an everyday
interaction between the races that you
don't see in many other places
new york has a reputation from its
founding as a melting pot a multi-ethnic
place ever since the dutch
founded it uh hundreds of years ago
today
you know what you see is also a very
complex reality you're right on the one
hand you have more races in closer
proximity in new york than anywhere else
um even the black community itself is is
complex you have uh caribbean americans
you have african americans originally
from the south you have african
americans
from new york city itself but you also
have entrenched patterns of spatial and
housing segregation as you say and this
uh
this began to take root
during the years of world war ii during
the years of the second great migration
which was when millions of african
americans
came from the south up to northern
cities
they settled in new york city harlem
already had a thriving black community
but for those migrants who didn't end up
in harlem
they were usually corralled into very
specific parts of brooklyn meaning the
neighborhood uh what we know of as
bedford stuyvesant now which is still
the heart of the black community in
brooklyn and as you're on your subway
train this is where you see many of the
african americans um getting on or
getting off right in the bedford
stuyvesant community no question about
it although the amount of gentrification
that's happening in bed stuy is also
incredible in the last five years
right
you know and and and this is an open
question in terms of what's going to
happen to the african-american community
in brooklyn um up against this
gentrification and the
the growing wealth really everywhere in
brooklyn but in those years of the 40s
and 50s
when african-americans came to brooklyn
and settled in bed-stuy
then you had a lot of whites moving out
of central brooklyn and moving to the
outer areas that you're talking about
bay ridge
bensonhurst and those communities became
sort of little white villages
in the middle of the century and then
uh you also had a lot of people starting
to a lot of white people starting to
move to long island and to the suburbs
in these same years um and so my book
does tell the story of how
brooklyn became racially segregated in
this way the irony is that
white people moved to their own
exclusive neighborhoods
in exactly the same years that they
started rooting for jackie robinson so
this is another sort of duality
complexity
that i show in in my book that on the
one hand the white brooklynites can
welcome robinson and proclaim themselves
to be the frontier of interracial
democracy on the one hand
and on the other
they can flee to their own segregated
exclusive neighborhoods where they don't
want to have anything to do with
african-american families
last thing jason in the limited time we
have left if if you had to say what the
the most important or powerful
potential truly unifying force when it
comes to race relations not one that
creates this kind of superficial
openness to racial integration but one
that truly has an impact what would it
be historically speaking
well i think when when communities have
committed themselves
to integrating their neighborhoods and
to integrating their schools
when white people have been willing to
make the quote-unquote sacrifice which
isn't actually any sacrifice
i think that's paid real dividends you
know when communities have committed
themselves to low-income and mixed
housing
and when
school systems have followed through on
radical widespread plans to to make sure
that their schools had actual
uh mixed makeups i i think those
communities have seen
positive returns and they've showed that
that it can be done we aren't we aren't
just fated to a segregated society
let me remind everybody the book is all
eyes are upon us race and politics from
boston to brooklyn we've been speaking
with the book's author professor jason
sokol from university of new hampshire
really great having you on thank you
thanks david